son muy buenos días desde caracas ayer
el gobierno de nicolás maduro mediante
su vicepresidenta del psis rodríguez
señalaba que lo que buscaban era
reanimar reavivar el comercio
internacional entre ambos países entre
colombia y venezuela que como tú viniste
desde 2005 ya venía de 2015 ya venía
afectándose recordemos que por ese este
este intercambio comercial entre ambos
países está intercambiaba entre 107 mil
500 millones de dólares y en 2019 luego
de estos cierres y estos bloqueos en la
frontera pues bajó 15 veces pero todavía
falta así el piso bueno de parte de las
autoridades de colombia ayer migración
colombia señalaba que hay que evaluar
cómo se encuentra este puente del puente
simón bolívar ya que estuvo con peso
muerto durante tanto tiempo